I did actually knock on our door a guy's
door once from Twitter you know did you
really yeah good so you know uh uh uh
DeAndre did this right no
um is it DeAndre no no no not DeAndre
Deontay Deontay Wilder Deontay Wilder
um there's a guy who talked [ __ ] and
there it's on video this guy talks [ __ ]
and Deontay Wilder showed up at a gym
that the guy was like no no no no this
is gonna happen right now yeah yeah this
is real okay yeah yeah this internet
troll oh yeah yeah Charlie's on and off
yeah yeah dude this this guy he this guy
talked [ __ ] and then he chased him he
was like no this is not over he's like
you talk [ __ ] to me good yeah that's
what the world needs more on and look
he's just [ __ ] oh
yeah that's how but that's how we used
to do it all right so wait I just wanted
to highlight that but you had a guy on
Twitter right so about three years ago
there was a liberal guy I can't for some
reason his name is escape my mind but if
you look up banter teacher he was an
English teacher who banned the word
banter and
yeah he's a real fat guy pure super
liberal what's his name Michael
something banter b-a-n-t-e-r teacher
bans banter look that up and you'll see
it and uh he was always begging for
money on Twitter because you know the
the right the right wing guys have uh
Mike studbury that's him yeah so this
this dude
he was constantly crying on Twitter I
need mental support can anyone give me
like a GoFundMe because of the right
wing and all this crap right so he
started running his mouth to me on
Twitter because he didn't let me tell
him the truth about the world telling me
I'm misogynist and all this [ __ ] and
just run his mouth to me and by absolute
freak coincidence I didn't even try
someone's like you know he lives in
Luton right I was like no [ __ ] way
which is where you were this is where
I'm from yeah he's like yeah he lives in
Luton I was like and then I was going
back to London because I just bought a
new Aston Martin vanquishes
you know one of them things you know you
leave Romania on the chat you go you
pick up your new Aston what's the first
place you're going to go and I was like
you know what by coincidence you just
wrote some more [ __ ] carpet misogynist
feminist I was like [ __ ] you so I drove
to his house if I can find it but I went
and knocked on his door and uh he had a
full mental breakdown
oh he had a full mental breakdown and
you what'd you say to him well this is
the funny thing right here we go so he's
blocked me now so he's he used to say he
doesn't drink but this is me taking a
picture of his trash can with all those
wine bottles he's like why so you don't
drink you alcoholic [ __ ] so I'm at his
door it's like but I'm not a violent guy
I don't hit him I don't know he laughs I
just want to talk to this podcast like
you make fun of me all day can I say
hello so I went and knocked on his door
and he started screaming out the window
I'm calling the police I'm calling the
police I was like bro I just want to
show you my new car what's the problem
so I started trying to talk to him the
police turn up the police Rock up let me
find the actual picture of me outside
his house because it's beautiful
it's very fashion this is refreshing a
little tea yeah so the police like
having too much of the no this is good
and uh what I said was very simple I
said look I'm a Jehovah's Witness I want
to spread the word of the Lord
I didn't know knocking on the I didn't
know knocking on the door was illegal
and what'd the police say well well he's
intimidated us I didn't I touched the
guy I don't know it's illegal I just
want to come to the name of the lord of
the Lord and they're like well go away
and then I got a lawyer my lawyer is
like well you've only been warned once
you can be worn four times
I was like yeehaw
I'm coming back Mike
I'm coming back
he actually moved houses he did
what
you should do more troll like yeah I
told you I'm doing a world tour I'm
getting warmed up like there I know
there's only a matter of time until I'm
banned for every single social media and
I don't exist anymore I don't know it's
fine I exist in the real world right and
your nightmares like Freddy Krueger oh
Tate's been banned for a year and a half
I wonder what he's doing knock knock
that's what I'm coming I'll find the
picture outside his house because it's
absolutely beautiful I just have to find
it now Sears a deal man is that some
people would accuse you of bullying
that's not bullying but he was bullying
you on Twitter no literally all he all
he did was insult me and all I wanted to
do was bring him closer to Christ and he
was upset with you by on Twitter about
what your your views telling the truth
about Earth you know normal things yeah
it's just existing oh you're you're this
you're that but this guy's this he's
this it's like shut up stop being a
little [ __ ] I literally want to just
record a video I actually was hoping to
have a normal interaction yeah I was I'm
zero percent the guy who's gonna attack
someone I know I come across that way
but I'm actually very intelligent I'm
not gonna get [ __ ] arrested for
beating some guys on Twitter so I want
to just talk to him and record it it's
gonna be funny but he crapped himself so
instantly and so monumentally but it was
just like became a thing I was I wish
you had Tristan filming and we were just
gonna I was gonna ask him why do you
think I'm feminist but he just
completely cracked himself really oh
yeah like really bad he was literally
crying out the window screaming on the
phone calling the police even the police
officers a man and a woman turned up I
said to the woman like come on this is a
bit extreme okay he's crying out the
window and she's kind of like well yeah
but you know he's scared I'm like no
this is just gay there it is Bam there
it is
me outside his house saying I love my
new car
if I didn't do nothing like I know this
is what we need to be in trouble with
somebody listen English please you've
arrested me enough right I didn't do
nothing I'm trying to spread the word of
the Lord I'm a Jehovah's Witness I
really want to bring him closer to
Christ yeah that was my only intention I
ain't hurt nobody plus you have three
more mornings you're fine it's like I
zoomed in on his house number on
accident oops
he's not there anymore no he's gone he's
gone he ran away what does he say so
just had these sent to me while waiting
for police banging on our door was
Andrew take kickboxer and someone else
someone else was my brother yeah this is
a few years that honestly like that has
to be pretty scary if you've talked if
you talk [ __ ] to a fighter
yeah right I mean especially somebody
that you think is an animal yeah it is
but yeah but but I think Mike Tyson Mike
Tyson said it all right he said social
media has people comfortable with
disrespecting each other without them
punching your face in the olden way of
man I would never disrespect someone to
their face unless I understood there
might be a physical confrontation
absolutely so you check your
consequences yeah the consequences now
there's no longer anything but you learn
that in [ __ ] grade school and you
know now if someone [ __ ] with your kid
and hits your kid and your kid hits that
kid back your kid will get in trouble
for for protecting themselves and that's
once again conditioning their conditions
nothing but I'm not going to get in
trouble when you get home stand up for
yourself oh yeah I know
you always said that I have I'll tell
you this I told my son because it's the
older one who I told him I go that's
okay I go if you get in trouble I'll
defend you if anybody ever tries to hurt
you you can you can hit them as hard as
you want but these little [ __ ] beta
[ __ ] don't learn those lessons because
you're not allowed to defend yourself
and then they get in positions of power
and then they look at [ __ ] Twitter
accounts like he remind he reminds me of
that yeah he reminds oh he's living his
life he's enjoying his life oh he's he
laughed he's smiling fan pan
even if he doesn't agree with your ideas
who gives a [ __ ] who the [ __ ] who cares
why does anybody give a [ __ ] what anyone
else thinks about anything it's full
weird it's full full clown World slave
mine and I mean look the programming the
programming it like I I create my
reality very very carefully like I don't
even really read my own YouTube comments
I don't really because because it's just
[ __ ] yeah I don't I really have an
existence where that's kind of funny
because I've kind of stopped reading
them like At first with YouTube I was
reading like pretty much everything
single comment and I've gotten to the
point where there's just like so many
stupid ass comments and I'm just like if
I'm scrolling through comments I'm like
yeah I'm wasting time right now this is
just this this is just consuming
nonsense you know what I mean people in
my network the people I do business with
my brother
around much of this
has a YouTube account called the based
mom or based Mom I don't know if the
word that is there and it's a picture of
me drinking a wine glass and uh that
person is out there and it's not me
but I really try and create my reality
very very carefully because it's
actually one of the things that's
amazing to me I said this the other day
everybody understands that you're the
sum of The Five People You spend the
most time with everybody understands
that Dan Pena everybody understands that
but they understand that and still hang
around with [ __ ] losers it's like
that is that not the ultimate Mark of
being a dumbass if you understand that
that's the truth and you don't create
your friendship and create your your
reality yes then you're a loser I had a
guy join the war room the other day my
private Network and he joined and we
have we have multi-millions in there
multi-millionaires in there we have a
billionaire in there I I bought a
Bugatti purely to add Bugatti owners to
my network so we have Bugatti owners in
there we have guys connected to the
point where I can't even say you on
YouTube right a guy joined he's 19. he
ain't nothing he goes look I know I
don't have any value to give but I'm
just here to learn and I I understand
that if I stand a chance of Escaping The
Matrix you're the man I need to be
around and I was like you're absolutely
intelligent so all the people out here
are sit there and go yeah you're the sum
of the five people you hang around with
the most yeah and then go hang around
with [ __ ] you're gonna you're an
idiot but most people are like that yeah
because they're idiots right you have to
create your reality and there's nothing
wrong with saying to people you know
what I've outgrown you you know what I'm
on a different
it really is the saddest thing when you
like really have to realize that but
it's the truth like when you're hanging
out with your friends all day and all
you guys do is smoke weed and [ __ ] off
and do nothing do you if you really want
to become successful man you got it you
gotta hang around with better people XYZ
sometimes you gotta caught people off
because if you don't create your reality
they infect your energy that is a big
one
but it right so yeah if it's negative
negativity that's one thing but even if
they're really good people and there is
no negativity but there's also a lack of
productivity and a lack of ambition and
the things that you want to get in your
life and intelligence that you know
you're just gonna you might be happy
because they're nice people but you're
just gonna sit there and smoosh them
forever
[Music]
writing on the wall won't last long